we're told this is the key for the
integer chips so this yellow circle with
a plus is equal to one this I guess
pinkish Circle Peach Circle it with a
minus that is equal to negative one
consider the following image and so that
we have a bunch of the positive yellow
circles and then we have even more of
the pink or Peach looking negative
circles complete the description of the
image there are blank zero pairs and
blank units left over if you're actually
doing this exercise this is a screenshot
from the exercise you would fill in
something here and there's a drop down
over here so the first question you
might ask is what is a zero pair
so a zero pair is when you take two
opposite numbers and they essentially
when you add them they cancel out to get
to zero an example of that would be one
plus negative one these two numbers are
opposites so they are zero pair because
when you add them together you get zero
why does that make sense well imagine if
positive values were walking forward and
negative values were walking backwards
so you could view this as one step
forward plus one step backward that's
just going to get you back to where you
were before you could have other zero
pairs you could have things like
positive two plus negative two that's
also a zero pair you walk two steps
forward and then two steps backward
that's just going to get you back to
where you were before you will not have
moved after all or you would you'd be
back to where you were before
so let's think about how many zero pairs
there are over here
well we know that each of the ones forms
a zero pair with each of the negative
ones so that's one zero pair two three
four five zero pairs so I'll just write
a five right over here you would type
that in if you were doing this and then
how many units are left over well you
could see right over here we see that we
have two of the negative one units left
over